néanmoins en zone gendarmerie on on
détecte enfin on identifie quand même
deux facteurs un peu plus nouveau alors
depuis les 5 5 dernières années d'abord
une tendance à la cannabiculture hein
donc que l'on voit de plus en plus
développer al c'est pas parce que les
zones sont plus rurales hein mais on a
cette cette cannabiculture qui se
développe avec euh un développement qui
à la fois est pour l'auto consommation
mais mais aussi derrière génère des
petites ventes localement et
deuxièmement mais ça c'est quelque chose
aussi qu'on retrouve dans les dans les
zones urbaines c'est si vous permettez
l'expression
libérisation de la de la vente des des
stupéfiants ù aujourd'hui avec les
messagesécryptés
euh tout le monde est un petit dealer
dans un coin et arrive à toucher dans un
secteur beaucoup de beaucoup de
personnes et beaucoup de cons ur
potentiel donc ces deux aspects se se
retrouvent chez nous